so let's just you got a profitable
business and a buyer approaches you
somebody wants to buy your business
maybe you want to raise more capital
maybe you're thinking about raising some
debt and you have to go hire an
investment banker what do you do we're
going to talk about that today
so two things if you get value from
today's content give it a thumbs up and
subscribe to the channel and i got a pdf
for you at the end so stick around so
let's go through it seven reasons to
hire an investment banker number one a
buyer has approached you they like your
business they say hey we want to buy
your business we like what you're doing
let's start talking you don't know what
your business is worth you don't want to
sell it too cheap you don't want to say
you're like i don't know what to do
maybe that's the reason you ought to
hire an investment banker number two you
want to raise some expansion capital you
you're you're starting to realize maybe
you can get into five markets if you had
an additional 20 million dollars maybe
if you hire certain engineers you can
expand maybe there's certain things you
can do with your current software but
you need an additional five ten fifteen
twenty hundred million dollars that's
expansion capital you need an investment
banker number three negotiating an
acquisition you're about to buy another
business you guys are coming together
you need one number four about to sell a
portion or entire business in the next
12 to 24 months the sale process is not
like i'm gonna buy i'm going to sell my
house 60 days later you sell a house
doesn't work like that generally it
takes a little longer five succession
plans six
capital constraint times are tough for
you you're running an airline like
airline industry needs money times are
tough you're running a good business
things are maybe you're growing too fast
you don't have money but if you have the
money you're shown you're growing but
your profit margins because
you're not going to get the money back
for three six months so you have to go
to somebody who raise money you get
capital restraints and last but not
least you're simply trying to learn the
process of what it's like if you hire an
investment banker and go on the market
to see if there's any interest for the
business that you have so having said
that 11 things to know before you hire
that investment banker number one do
they know your industry for example if i
i'm sitting with an investment banker
and he's an expert in pharmaceutical
companies he saw the last 20 companies
he sold they're all pharmaceutical
companies but on financial industry it
doesn't matter he could be the best in
that industry his rolodex is people from
that industry so investment banker who
knows nothing about your industry even
though they may be the best it's
irrelevant typically you want somebody
that's in your industry because they
have the expertise number two
how many deals have they done in your
industry recently so for example you'll
ask the question so they'll say to you
let's just say your real estate company
well yeah you know i have a
we've done real estate deals and you
know upwards of raising 50 million
dollars and we've also sold a couple
real estate companies for 200 million or
300 million dollars great which ones are
they they'll show you the list of
companies xyz company abc
and all the stuff they'll give you and
you say were you a lead banker on this
oh no we were doing it with xy you know
such and such other investment banker
but were you the leader were daily they
were the lead but we were still working
together as a team they're not a lead so
they're still small to the other guys so
maybe you write down who was the person
you were oh we were working with you
know john whatever okay got it perfect
you're starting to learn to see if
they're leader on these deals or not and
don't give any stories sometimes they're
going to say yeah we did that you know
like well you did that oh yeah we let
the whole thing did you have anybody
else no it was all us the entire way did
you do the other yeah we also did this
one did you do that we also did this one
this may be the investment banker that
it's no longer about
them selling you now it's more about you
selling them because they're the ones
that are going to get to the buyers that
you want to talk to so you have to
understand
who they are what type of experience
they got number three size of the deal
i've sat down with investment bankers
but we go to new york and sit down and
talk to some of these guys yeah we sell
insurance companies what size 25 million
50 million 100 million too small so some
people's size of deal they do is too
small some people's size of deal they do
is way too big i spoke to the goldman
sachs investment bankers they said
listen our minimum is a two billion
dollar sale three billion dollars so
great
specs that we do we don't do any specs
less than a billion dollars great but
you're understanding their size so you
don't want somebody that's too big
because they're going to be so bored of
selling your property your business and
you don't want anybody too small the
best way to look at it is the following
way
say you have a million dollar home for
sale you don't want to talk to a realtor
who's never sold a million dollar home
they only sell 400 000 homes but you
also don't want to talk to the realtor
that only sells 20 million homes because
he's not interested in the commissions
of selling a 1 million home hopefully
that makes sense that's why you asked
the size of the deal number four are
they telling you what you want to hear
are they telling you what you need to
hear
if if a person that's an investment
banker the amateur one gets typically
too excited
oh we're gonna get you exactly the price
so and i think we can even do more
that's rookie realtors say things like
that that's rookie investment
backgrounds tell you things like that
and you if you get excited that's also a
reflection of you being a rookie in a
market that you've never dealt with this
before and you get oh my god he said he
can get us you know 40 ebitda 20 times
ebitda he's just getting you excited
right depending on what they're doing
versus somebody says i hate
what are your numbers well here's a
challenge are we going to face are you
prepared for that because what do you
think your business is worth i don't
think the market market's paying that
today here's what the market is paying
let's look at the comps this is what
it's looking like you know if your
expectations to get something like this
how are we going to make that case to
get to the number that you want you're
not necessarily a tech enabled business
yet you don't have a management team yet
you know what's your you know supporting
cast look like so i don't think you're
ready or what's your management
something like this oh wow that's your
management team yes oh what's your
support team what software do you oh you
are oh we could go for a number like
this but if they're just telling you
what you want to hear they're not
telling you what you need to hear may
not be the guy for you number five ask
for a list of contacts they plan on
approaching for example say you've spent
hours and hours with them so johnny let
me ask you based on what now what you
know now about our business who do you
think would be a
potential buy for something like this
well here's a list of 40 people that i
would probably approach
and these are some of the companies that
we'll be talking about we've done
business before and they they take our
calls because we've done three deals
with these guys four deals with these
guys and then they'll show you some of
them are in this field some of them are
on this field but they're kind of giving
you an idea of who could what the buyer
could potentially look like based on the
context that they have do they ask you
the right questions so the right
questions are technical questions so for
example
so uh
the c-suite executives you've hired how
much experience you have with your
company how long have they been there
have they only been there for a month or
two or have they been on for a year plus
well there was okay so so they have to
now think okay so in regards to your
ebitda what's your ebitda look like the
last 12 months 24 months 36 months 48
months here's what it looks like okay
that sounds good what's your top line
revenue looking like maybe even though
it's going up or your top line revenue's
not going up what's the problem there
are you just figuring out ways to make
more profit because that doesn't they
have to ask the right question like the
questions that you're hoping they don't
ask you to have to ask you that's what a
great investment banker does because
they have to know that the buyer is
going to want to know that stuff so they
better know those things now before they
go into the market to talk to buyers
number seven do they have a solid team
around them the lead guy you want to be
able to buy into the lead guy or lead
gal but then who else is around them who
else is supporting where they're going
to be able to say here's what i think
here's what i think with this because
sometimes when you go into a room with
investment bankers they'll have
typically it's a group of three people
that'll talk to you the lead the co
and then the person that's the junior
analyst that's sitting there trying to
figure out a way to maybe not get the
deal done one person is very excited
about the doing the deal one person is
not excited about doing the deal one
person knows nothing about the deal but
they're reasonable and they're willing
to sit there and talk that's typically
the dynamics of the three people that
are in the room so it's a form of
getting audited but you want to know who
their team is well number eight what do
they think the buyer will look like will
be a strategic will be a pe firm will be
a bank so they may say i don't think the
strategist is going to be interested in
your company why here's why okay i i
don't think a private equity firm is
going to be interested in your company
here's why i i don't think a bank's
going to buy something like this
intercom i think bank may be it i mean i
think private equity i think strategic
may be good they're going to probably
ask you to follow seven questions are
you ready for these following eight
questions so then they'll start asking
you questions that a buyer asking but
you have to know what they think the
buyer is going to look like so they'll
say
there's probably a five percent chance
that's going to be a pe firm i think 95
chance is going to be strategic oh
really yes
okay fantastic let's look at what that
let's see what that looks like number
nine ask them why they believe they can
do the job like why can they go raise
the money or do the
acquisition why can they help you sell
the company why did i think we can do it
because of pop-pop pop-pop great very
helpful number 10 understand fee
structure fee structure works out in
different ways some may ask for money up
front now money up front may be
if you're doing a deal that the
commission is going to end up being 5
million bucks 10 million bucks a million
dollars let's just use a million dollars
that's an easy fee
if they're asking for a quarter up front
they're not going to do the job like but
if they say hey i need 20 000 50 000 100
because that's gonna cover our fees
until we get paid these guys are now
doing this business for twenty thousand
dollar check twenty thousand dollar
check for a price for an investment
macro means nothing
fifty thousand is nothing they're trying
to get a you know
two five ten million dollar check that's
what they're going for
so if there's a little bit of money up
front you can negotiate that you don't
want it to be too much you want it to be
enough when they're doing the traveling
dinner all that stuff that they got to
cover
that part makes sense the second one is
fee structure how they put it up hey
we're going to get
if it's a smaller company they're going
to get a bigger percentage if it's a
bigger company you're going to get a
somewhat smaller percent so for example
hey it's i'm a one percent i'm two
percent i'm three percent on four
percent they'll put their number up
there right you can come back and say i
want it to be uh uh tiers so if you sell
it between you know
uh uh you know 50 to 100 million it's
this price 100 to 150 million is this
price 200 to 500 million is this price
500 whatever the tiers you put up and
you can say the more you sell it for you
know the percent is going to be whatever
that's something that you can negotiate
with your investment banker and last but
not least is the earn out
sometimes the investment banker is going
to want to get the whole money upfront
even though you as the buyer haven't
gotten full money from the seller yet
from the buyer yet because they want to
do an earn up maybe they'll give you 90
money upfront and you'll earn out the
10. maybe they'll give you 80 up front
and they'll earn out to 20. but the
investment banker wants to get paid on
the 80 and to 20 up front whether that
20 happens or not you can't obviously
that's your ability to negotiate but you
need to know that that's what they're
going to be asking you when you do deal
with them and last but not least
ask for the last five deals that didn't
go through and why so john this is great
you guys got a lot of experience that
sounds really good i think we're getting
kind of to a point where we're
comfortable with this this is our sixth
meeting together can you tell me about
the last five deals you guys didn't do
and why
well yeah great uh i'm glad you're
asking that question number one one of
the deals that we didn't do because the
ceo uh
was not willing to stay with the company
and he told us at first he was and then
he changed his mind the buyers like what
do you mean we can't buy this business
he has no other leadership team there's
no way we can buy business like this no
problem
the other one is we made the mistake we
didn't do enough the you know due
diligence and because of that now we've
added this additional due diligence
process of three hours of asking
questions coming to your home office
learning about your management team
whatever it is they're gonna tell you
the five deals that they didn't go
through because you are gonna learn the
most based on that question on deals
that didn't go through not deals that
did go through this is what you want to
know and you can ask that question from
all the 10 different investment bankers
you'll interview
you'll get so much knowledge from doing
that so having said that if you took a
lot away from today's
episode i have a pdf for you as well
give it a thumbs up if you learned a lot
today and subscribe to the channel and
text the word
investment banker to
310-340-1132-310-340-1132 text the word
investment banker will send you pdf of
all the things that was written here
today and if you're out of the country
you're not in the states go in the
description click on the link below
subscribe to our newsletter and we'll
send the pdf to you as well until you
enjoy this video i got another video for
you titled how to raise money if you've
never seen this video it's very detailed
on how to raise money click over here to
watch the video take care everybody bye
[Music]